tell us a little bit about yourself
Matthias well
um right now I'm having a radio show
I've just started the 11th season of our
radio program that's exciting you have a
radio show that's why you gave us the
weather yeah he just does it oh yes
how's the traffic
um so matteus tell us about your radio
show that's exciting it's been going on
11 seasons
11 Simpsons yes and um well the problem
is that nobody listens to us but
otherwise it's going great when you say
nobody when you say nobody listens give
me an actual figure of how many people
listen to the radio show
about four oh maybe three people
I thought you meant like only a couple
of only a couple of thousand people I
didn't realize you have a radio show and
and three people listen are we the three
people and you're doing the show right
now yeah you counting us I think no he
just doubled his numbers oh wow no
exactly yes this is a big uh
International pick no but
um yeah they probably miss the radio
station is small and the largest like
radio show maybe has a couple hundred uh
listeners yes and so we are not that bad
in that sense uh but the only people
that listens to us are just you know
family members and so you have a radio
show and the only people that listen uh
is your family
yes and not even all my family because
it would be larger than three or four
people
of your family that you have a radio
show
and they know uh but they don't you know
actually come and listen to the show
they should that's terrible I mean they
don't have to listen every time but they
should check it out once in a while do
your parents listen to this podcast not
once
they think they think that I'm an
insurance salesman
um uh well listen Matthias I know what
it's like I I know what it's like I've
had some tough times in my career when I
felt no one was uh had my back and uh
but you've got to persevere you've got
to keep going do you understand you you
can't it is you can't lose Faith you
must keep going and right now you have
four people listening but if you keep
working hard five people will listen
then six then one day seven then back to
five because two will die so this is how
it works but you've got to keep going
what's your uh radio show called so we
can plug it well uh the show is called
decaf news like decaffeinated news oh
decaf news Okay this may be a conflict
of interest but have you considered also
releasing this radio program as a
podcast without I mean we tried
everything
yes wait wait so yeah let's let's just
clear this up here this is important so
Matthias you're saying that Matt
suggested you maybe release it as a
podcast and he said you've done that and
that didn't work either
um no but the thing is Matthias can you
think of any way that I might be able to
help you well maybe
I don't know you had a lot of experience
in changing the format and getting
people you know hooked during different
times so maybe there's like an idea for
a new
um contest or a new piece of uh
content that we can maybe offer or a
different thing to shake things up yeah
I mean to get people here's what I can
promise you Matthias is that you
currently have uh four listeners that
you're related to yes I can improve your
listenership I can't say by how much for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers I uh
learned Spanish just many times over
yeah it didn't really stick no well
you're very Irish
okay that doesn't have anything to do
and it's not like you went home to
anyone who spoke Spanish you just need
to practice it that's one thing my
father's from Spain oh I know he's a
matador anyway now thanks to Babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn
the new language babble's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go with Babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including
Spanish French Italian German there are
so many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games video stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee you know when I go
to another country I like to have some
facility with the language because it
shows that you're trying yeah it's like
a very uh courteous thing to do but it
could be tedious if it's like boring how
to learn it but this is fun I've tried
Babel and it is really fun they they do
teach you things that you'll use when
you go to another country and and it's
stuff that sticks right now get up to 55
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com Team Coco that's babel.com
teamcoco for up to 55 off your
subscription that's a big chunk off your
welcome World Babble language for life
should you do an actual active call for
all listeners to go download decaf news
I think we could do that we could do a
week well there might be a language
barrier there because we speak in
Spanish but uh I don't know
yeah see you're comprendal see it's
important
Marlon Brando suddenly Eduardo is
laughing at me
he did he did you know so
um
listen I think I could help you I could
write an ad in Spanish I could read it
in Spanish it would be fluent it would
sound terrific and I could record that
ad for you and then we could get you
some play and we could get you uh some
help what if we just have uh Matthias if
you could give Conan one line in Spanish
that he could read right now for the
show that's like hey this is Conan
O'Brien listen to decaf news in Spanish
even though most of that is would be
English but okay
okay you got to slow it down
okay listen okay yeah I know I got this
so decaffeinated news yeah in Reverse
escucha notices
see and what's the time and the number
and all that
um yes it's at um
Symphony and what was the last part
gladio Symphony so radio Symphony yeah
is this going to make a difference 91.3
oh no you know I know your servers are
going to be able to handle this
now
practice this a few times okay let me
get let me try one as a practice
hola amigos O'Brien
escucha noticias de caffeinado
and radio Symphony 91.3
that's pretty good that's great that's
awesome we try one more emphasis on the
wrong words
to shut up it's right there
isn't it doing something wrong is there
some way that it could be better
let me try one more
here we go hola amigos yo soy Conan
O'Brien
Symphony 91.3 wow come on now tell me
that's not going to make a difference
right now I have to ask you an awkward
show that's the numbers
when people hear Conan O'Brien are they
going to know
who that is
uh I hope so uh wow you're just
injecting pure confidence what do you
lie about who you are why don't you say
your message oh yeah oh yeah yeah who
would Lionel Messi be the guy who would
be the best guy and he's right yeah okay
here we go here we go this is gonna help
you okay
Amigos yo soy
is noticias
yes
91.3 now do a Vita
yo soy Evita
okay this has gotten too stupid this has
gotten way too stupid
Jesus Christ or Amigos yourself
here we go let's try it again
hola amigos yo soy
Lionel Messi it's your dad see Lionel
Messi
escucha noticious
Symphony 91.3 now say are you really
messy are you really messy uh see you're
so messy
that proves it's messy yes I think we
just had to reassure a lot of times that
he was messy proves that he's messy
yes you're right messy messy in real
life is constantly saying yes I am messy
yes